J'ai été kidnappé un homme est entré par effraction dans ma maison
et s'est faufilé dans ma chambre et a tenu un couteau
à mon cou et m'a dit de me lever et d'aller
avec lui ou il me tuerait J'ai été
enchaîné J'ai été violé quotidiennement parfois plusieurs
fois par  Le jour où il m'a forcé à boire de l'
alcool pour me droguer,
il a très méthodiquement essayé de me dépouiller
de mon identité
de tous les liens que j'avais avec
des amis de la famille en menaçant de me tuer
en menaçant de tuer ma famille
en disant qu'il y aurait de graves
conséquences si  J'ai continué à parler
d'eux
[Musique]
pas immédiatement mais des années après que je sois devenu de
plus en plus impliqué dans le plaidoyer
en dénonçant la violence sexuelle
et en dénonçant le blâme des victimes
en essayant de faire une différence afin que
ce qui m'est arrivé ne soit pas  ça arrive à d'
autres personnes
[Musique]
J'entends cette question pourquoi n'as-tu pas couru
pourquoi n'as-tu pas crié pourquoi n'as-tu pas crié pourquoi n'as-
tu pas dit quelque chose j'ai
entendu tu devrais t'amuser
tu aurais dû crier tu ne l'as pas fait  en faire
assez il ne doit pas avoir  J'ai été si mal
parce que tu n'as rien fait pour essayer de
t'enfuir, peu importe si tu étais
à la maison au lit ou ou si tu es dans un bar
ivre mort tu sais qu'il
y a des choses dans  ce monde qu'il
n'y aura jamais de circonstance
qui arrangera les choses et le viol est l'une d'
entre elles depuis des années victimes je me sentais si
isolé si seul personne ne veut
parler personne ne veut devenir cette personne
avec la lettre écarlate sur la poitrine
mais maintenant depuis  le mouvement de rencontre Je
pense que les victimes ont de plus en plus l'
impression qu'elles peuvent s'exprimer qu'elles ont
toute une famille de survivants autour d'elles
[Musique]
Je veux dire que je veux que les victimes soient traitées avec
respect et dignité Je veux que les gens
arrêtent de les regarder  comme s'ils avaient fait
quelque chose de mal parce qu'ils ne l'avaient pas fait et
ce n'est pas juste pour eux et probablement pas
plus que tout ne nous aidera à
avancer en ayant le droit de faire
nos propres choix